hello and welcome to another video today
we're going to be talking about the
movie phone booth so if you haven't
watched this film beware of spoilers
right let's jump into it New York's the
home to an estimated 8 million people
and when technology continuously
evolving phone booths are gradually
becoming obsolete easily being replaced
by cell phones Stu Shepard's an arrogant
New York City publicist who's
contemplating cheating on his wife Kelly
who uses a phone booth at 53rd and 8th
and removes his wedding ring while
making a call he calls Pam a young
actress from the phone booth however
just before he's about to make the call
a delivery man tries to deliver a free
pizza to the booth but Stu rudely
dismisses him saying he must have
mistaken him for someone else the
delivery guy insists that he's not
mistaken he's embarrassed but he's
forced to take the money and go when Stu
cusses at him before giving him five
dollars and instructing him to eat the
pizza himself Stu then proceeds to call
Pam she picks it up and Ponders as to
why he uses the same phone booth every
day after talking for a while she
informs her that he's brought up a lead
role for her in an upcoming Mel Gibson
film he then asked Pam to meet her later
that night but she refuses Stu gets
disappointed however she promises to
meet him the next day and hangs up after
the phone call with Pam the phone rings
the caller says that he should have
accepted the pizza as it would have kept
his strength up for what's about to
happen next the mysterious caller also
wants you not to leave the booth he
thinks it's just a prank call and tries
to hang up but the man again warns him
not to he also says that he will learn
to obey him Stu again really dismissive
is skeptical towards the mystery caller
he asks who he is but the caller simply
says he's an admirer of Stew stew
becomes aware of his surroundings and
searches for the caller the man then
begins to describe what Jews wearing
prompting him to ask where he is the
caller urges him to check the windows
but Stu's not sure that the caller is
observing him when the caller gets it
right he raises his hand in the air and
raises his middle finger which offends
the man the caller tells him that that's
not kind the call then resize Stu's full
name and address and tells him that he
knows who Pamela is he starts
threatening Stu telling him that
disconnecting the phone isn't in his
best interest and that someone could be
hurt if he does Stu once again threatens
the caller he asks him if this is his
assistance bidding or not he asks him to
hang up the call the caller says that he
will say hi to Kelly for him then hangs
up leaving Stu visibly concerned he
tries to call him back but this time he
doesn't get a response Stu steps outside
the phone booth invisible frustration
and then the phone rings again Stu asks
him if he's an actor and the man
jokingly says that he is the caller then
instructs him to dial the number he died
when he first entered the phone booth
Stu acts as though he has no idea what
the man's talking about but the man
claims that he's already written down
the number and that he can see every
number that Stu pressed because Stu
refuses to call Pam the Mad finds her
personally which perplexes stew when she
picks up the phone the corner puts her
on speaker so Stu can hear her Pam's
greeted by a caller who entered reduces
himself as one of Stu's friends when Pam
tries to talk to Stu and asks if what
the man said is true he futile he tells
her to hang up the phone but the caller
informs you that Pam can't hear him and
the caller tells her the Stu hasn't been
completely honest with her the caller
reveals to Pam that she was married to a
woman named Kelly and to hide the fact
that he's disloyal to her he calls
through a phone booth during this
conversation a hooker approaches the
phone booth but still tells it to go
away the woman gets angry and curses him
before leaving Stu asks the man why he's
doing all of this he then tells Stu to
call his wife and tell her the truth
otherwise he will Stu asks him what he
should tell Kelly and the man says he
should tell her the truth that he's been
cheating on her Stu claims that he's
done no such thing the hooker comes back
again and demands to use the phone
however Stu fends her off saying that
she can use some other she gets agitated
and curses at him she threatens that
she's going to be back and he'll regret
it but Stu pays no attention the
mysterious call has been observing the
whole thing and love house having no
other choice he calls her number his
wife picks up and reveals that she was
informed about Stu calling her before he
has a chance to tell Kelly the truth
he's distracted by three prostitutes who
want to use the foam they start
harassing him upon hearing this Kelly
asks Stu what's happening the
prostitutes become hostile due to Stew's
refusal to leave the booth and they
start banging against the glass between
all the hassle the quarter keeps asking
him to tell his wife that he's been
planning to sleep with another woman Stu
says that they should leave Kelly out of
it but the corner just keeps on
insisting he pushes Stu to put the phone
down but the caller says that if he
hangs up again he will shoot him he
doesn't believe him and says how he'll
shoot him with a pair of binoculars and
the caller replies he's looking at him
with the highly magnified scope of his
sniper rifle he still doesn't believe it
but is convinced when the man [ __ ] his
rifle now she do gets scared warning him
that if he shoots the cops will arrive
however the sniper proves him to be
wrong by shooting a toy robot next to
the booth without anybody even noticing
after some time another hooker shows up
the Stu ignores her as he looks around
trying to search for the caller the
Unseen Man reveals that he had
previously set up two other dishonest
individuals in a similar situation where
he gave them a chance to redeem
themselves but since both refused he had
to kill them then the caller asks Stu
where he's pointing his gun at and he
notices a red dot of laser on his chest
the situation escalates further when the
prostitutes in their pimp Leon
approached the booth and demands due to
leave terrified that he's going to be
shot now Stu refuses the deadlock
between him and Leon escalates to the
point of Leon breaking into the booth
and attacking him the sniper tells Stu
if he can help him and he says yes Leon
is shot in the back by the sniper
horrifying the prostitutes the hooker
start accusing stew loudly and say that
he has a gun he informs the caller that
he did everything he could to get Leon
to leave him alone but the man refused
the caller then informs him that Leon
wouldn't have died if she had treated
him with respect and it needs to grow up
and accept responsibility for his
actions secretly now Stu dials 9-1-1 and
tries to give a hint to the operator
while talking to the mysterious man the
man shoots one side of the phone booth
and the bullet accidentally injures tube
he then realizes that the man must have
bugged the phone booth to monitor
everything shortly after the police
arrive and stews instantly the suspect
he doubts that they'll find any evidence
to suggest his guilt in the murder
Captain Ed raymie arrives and tries to
negotiate with Stu to exit the booth but
he says that he can't get off the call
and is talking to his psychiatrist
Captain Remy continues to speak with him
to persuade him to surrender to add to
the Intrigue the caller instructs Stu to
insult the captain he disagrees but the
call that threatens to shoot the captain
if he doesn't follow the orders the
captain walks away without responding to
Stu's remarks but not before telling one
of the cops to contact a techie who can
help them with the pay foam multiple
news bands arrive at this point and
reporters begin filming the situation
putting pressure on the police to deal
with the situation without appearing
trigger happy Captain Raymond instructs
his men to track the numbers Jews
calling suddenly its juice phone starts
ringing but he's unable to attend to it
because the cops might suspect him now
Kelly arrives on the scene she tells
Captain raymie about the man who had
called her at the shop earlier but the
captain believes it's just another case
of a jealous husband the captain tries
to communicate with Stu with the help of
Kelly however just to ensure Kelly's
safety Stu says he's got no idea who
that woman is the corner then threatens
to shoot Kelly Stu asks him what he
wants and he says that Stu should
confess his wrongdoings to her Stu who's
frustrated from the entire situation
declares that he's turning himself in
Stu then tells Kelly everything about
him and Pam upon hearing this Kelly
gives little to no reaction saying she
simply didn't care what he'd done in the
past the phone rings again and as Kelly
grows impatient she tries to get nishtu
causing the caller to point the gun at
her when the captain sees the red laser
dot on Kelly's forehead he orders
everyone to stand down Stu convinces the
captain to let him answer the phone own
again now realizing the situation the
captain advises they're men to be on the
lookout for a sniper in the building in
front of them the caller now reveals
that he plans to frame stew for the
murder of Leon he reveals that he's
placed a gun on the roof of the phone
booth the caller then teases dude to
look to a window with pink curtains
hinting that he's there and asks him to
use the gun to shoot him the caller only
laughs he tells you that he's right and
that he's not even in that window the
caller continues to taunt him by telling
him to take hold of the planted gun but
he refuses hammerize on the scene and
the corner tells him that he'll take one
of them out if she refuses to pick up
the gun Stu pleads with the sniper one
at the same time secretly using his cell
phone to call Kelly who secretly informs
captain raymie of the sniper's presence
when Remy hears the conversation the
caller doesn't notice this because Stu
is out of sight the captain then informs
his troops what to do while making sure
they don't alert the caller he also
orders Kelly to stay in the car Captain
Remy speaks to Stu once again implying
that he knows there's a sniper in one of
the buildings and then his troops are
ready to act once they discover him he
also implies that Stu can trust him and
that it's safe to leave the phone booth
upon the caller's threat Shu confesses
his bad character to the crowd telling
his unpaid assistant Adam who looks up
to Stu not to become a publicist and
admitting that he's a fake she explains
he's not as rich as he seems the police
finally Tracked Down the sniper by
tracing the core the sniper made to
Kelly and raymie tells stew through a
cryptic message that they've done so
stream forms the sniper that the cops
are coming to get him and the now
enraged sniper chooses to take Kelly
with him seeing as she's the most
important thing in his life panicked Stu
takes the planted gun runs out of the
phone booth then stew a shot and falls
down just as police break into a hotel
room discovering a dead body a phone and
a sniper rifle it's then revealed that
Stu's been hit by a rubber bullet from a
police sniper leaving him relatively
unharmed Kelly runs over and kisses stew
who's still on the ground the police
wheel the body they found in the hotel
room down onto the street and Kelly
insists on seeing the sniper's body Stu
identifies the body as the pizza
delivery man she's recovering under
morphine in an ambulance which makes him
drowsy A man carrying a large suitcase
walks up to him and complements his
shoes the man says that he regrets
killing the piece to delivery guy and
warns you that if his Newfound honesty
doesn't last that he's going to be
hearing from him again he walks away and
smiles as he passes the phone booth
revealing himself to be the caller stew
Falls unconscious
so this is it for today's video if you
like the video give it a huge Thumbs Up
And subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time